Want some soup?
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my Mandalorian episode for
video there was all kinds of Easter eggs
so we'll break it down if you're new to
the channel I'm doing videos for all the
episodes be sure to subscribe to get
everything we're doing a weekly merch
giveaway careful for spoilers if you
have not seen the episode yet so we'll do
top 10 and easter eggs as we go
along starting with number 10 the title
and the inspiration for the episode so
the episode was titled sanctuary it was
meant to be in episode where they go on
vacation for a couple of months as you
would expect things do not go as planned
but the episode itself is based
completely on the plot of Seven Samurai
you could also say magnificent seven but
Magnificent Seven was kind of a remake
of Seven Samurai and a little bit of
hidden fortress most longtime Star Wars
fans will recognize that those Akira
Kurosawa samurai films were the basis
for the original Star Wars trilogy so
they're going for some really deep cut
ester eggs here the episode did a great
job of showcasing just how much they can
do with that baby Yoda puppet on set
practically they use a little bit of
special effects to sweeten it but for
the most part it's a practical puppet
that they use on set
there was also an episode of Star Wars
the Clone Wars that did this exact same
plot from this episode called bounty
hunters but Dave Filoni ran that show
Dave felonio so works on this show with
Jon Favreau so no surprise that there's
always a lot of Clone Wars Easter eggs
and episodes if you've never watched
those samurai films Seven Samurai is
basically a group of samurai that are
hired to protect a village that have to
teach the village how to defend itself
against a group of Raiders but number
nine the episode begins on the village
on a planet called sore again which is
brand new to Star Wars they created it
for the TV show the villagers are mostly
farming krill to sell to the local
market it's used to create those blue
drinks that you see them drinking later
in the episode in those vats if that
wasn't clear the leader of the village
is O'Mara
you probably recognize her from
Westworld season 2 or maybe the Twilight
movies there's a big callback to the
baby Yoda joke with him eating the Frog
when her daughter tries to catch one and
fails they pay it off later in the
episode when baby Yoda teaches them how
to catch it like a ninja
their village is rated by a bunch of
creatures from Klaatu Wien if you're not
familiar with that planet those aliens
actually showed up a little bit in the
original trilogy and back an attack of
the clones but you haven't seen them a
whole lot before number eight back on
the razor crest things were a little
more chill baby Yoda won't stop playing
with all the buttons in the cockpit and
the Mandalorian starts yelling at him
you start to get a better sense for his
level of intelligence in his personality
when he knowingly starts messing with
the Mandalorian by flipping the buttons
after he tells him to stop he's like a
little kid who won't stop messing with
the door lock buttons or the window
controls on a long family car trip but
when the Mandalorian was weighing his
options for a place to hide out for a
few months it's a lot like the scene of
Han Solo trying to find a place to hide
out from the Empire after they fled Hoth
and Empire Strikes Back and just like an
empire Darth Vader finding them at Cloud
City the same thing happens to the mando
and baby Yoda on sorg on the bounty
hunters start to find them he drops a
big easter egg for a new hope when he
calls baby Yoda a little womp rat later
in the episode he tries to get
bull's-eyed by a womp rat by one of the
other bounty hunters - the thing about
womp rats though is that they're local
to Tatooine which implies that the
Mandalorian has been to Tatooine before
for those of you wondering if they'd
ever travel there on the series we
haven't been there yet on the
Mandalorian and they're mostly going to
new planets but don't be surprised
because Tatooine is also in the Outer
Rim territories because most of the
episode was them in chill mode they also
used it as an opportunity to show you
how much baby Yoda is mobile and could
go around by himself most of the time
we've only seen him being carried around
in that bassinet or carried in the
Mandalorians arms but he's deceptively
intelligent and almost seems like he has
teleportation powers with the way he
just shows up magically behind the
Mandalorian anytime you're not watching
him number seven inside the alien
cantina there's a huge Star Wars rebels
Easter Egg you all probably recognized
when baby Yoda is walking around just
taking in all the sights
everything looks huge to him because
he's so small he passes by this giant
cat whose mouth is bigger than his
entire body
that's called a Loth Cat it's local to
Lothal all from the Star Wars rebels
series that's where most of that series
took place and speaking of Star Wars
rebels and Star Wars Clone Wars stuff
showing up on the mandalorian series
remember all that stuff happened
way back before the original trilogy
this is happening after the original
trilogy but Dave Filoni himself implied
that we would be seeing characters from
those original series Clone Wars and
rebels showing up on the Mandalorian in
live-action form he didn't say which
characters but obviously it's going to
be different for every different Disney
plus live-action series so for instance
the obi-wan series is going to take
place between Episode three in Episode
four where ahsoka is much younger it's
much more possible for her to show up on
that series than it is for her to show
up on the Mandalorian number six the
Mandalorian versus Cara dune we meet
cara dune Gina Carano's character you
all probably recognized her instantly
she's been doing press all year for the
show they've been hyping her up as one
of the big characters of the new series
we learn about some of the special
tracking technologies that the
Mandalorian has built into his helmet
when he goes to find her thinking that
she might be there for them there's
probably a whole bunch of other secret
weapons that he has built into his suit
that we'll see in future episodes but
they wind up throwing down Gina Carano
mostly known for being an MMA fighter
before she became an actress so of
course they cast her and they're going to
give her a big fight scene I was hoping
that there would be some masters of
Terra Cotta reference just because it's
such a deep cut but they mostly just
brawl the Mandalorian tries to use his
flamethrower again he really really
likes that flamethrower he's used it in
every single episode but then baby Yoda
shows up like a ninja slurping on his
soup to break the tension do you want
some soup we learned a little bit about
Cara doones backstory she says she's an
ex rebel shock trooper who was cleaning
up Imperials after the Battle of Endor
when she named drops going after ex
Imperial warlords those are basically
the generals in the admirals left in the
appear old fleet after the Empire or the
remnants of the Empire fled to the outer
rim to become the first order that'll be
important for later in the series
because Giancarlo Esposito is playing
someone who used to be an imperial moth
who was in charge of an entire sector
the sector that they're flying around in
now on the Mandalorian series then
number five we get our big Boba Fett
Easter Egg when the two villagers ask
him if he's not a Mandalorian and he's
just wearing their armor that's actually
an Easter Egg for Boba Fett and Jango
Fett neither one of them were actual
Mandalorians just people who wore
Mandalorian armor he kind of explains
their logic later in the episode part of
their code is that they never take their
helmet
off or else you can't put it back on
that's basically your sign that you're
quitting being a Mandalorian and if you
go back and you watch Attack of the
Clones you see Jango Fett walking around
through most of that movie without his
helmet on there are a couple exceptions
to when they can take their helmet off I
don't know if he's taken it off in the
presence of the kid yet but I'm assuming
that he will do that before the end of
the series Mandalorians are also allowed
to take their helmets off in the
presence of their significant other
someone that they're married to or made
it to for life or their children that's
why I think the big payoff at the end of
the season you know us maybe see him
take his helmet off will only be for the
kid but the two bumbling villagers that
come searching for the Mandalorian is a
bit of a hidden fortress Easter egg and
it's also a big callback to r2d2 and
c3po taking the perspective of two low
level characters to get across a whole
bunch of exposition they go back to the
village there's a couple funny moments
with the kids playing with baby Yoda and
then eventually Cara Doon in the
Mandalorian go and find that the Raiders
have an AT-ST and try to call things off
the villagers aren't having it so number
four they train the villagers to fight
this is really where you get to the
Seven Samurai montages during the film
preparing the village for this big
Raider attack the Mandalorian arms them
all with weapons from the razor crest in
surprise their leader Omera is a crack
shot they imply that there's some secret
history that she has on the show some
crazy backstory that they're not telling
you
Cara Doon drops an Empire Strikes Back
reference talking about damaging the
legs of the AT-ATs then they said they
have to set a trap for it this is also a
big reference to return of the Jedi
where you have a bunch of low tech
people like the Ewoks trying to fight a
bunch of high tech Imperials number
three the Mandalorian and Cara doon
versus the Klaatu in Raiders they take
out a giant chunk of them but they
weren't there to kill all the Raiders
they were just there to get them all
riled up so that they would follow them
back to the trap that they had laid at
the village when they blow up the tent
with that charge and all those big vats
that's basically them blowing up all of
their beer so to speak so yeah that
would definitely piss them off
the special effects for the a AT-ST were
great my only disappointment with all
those scenes is that you never actually
got to see inside the cockpit of it like
you would see inside Empire Strikes Back
my guess is is that just for budgetary
reasons maybe in a future season they'll
go for full-blown AT-ATs at
some point number two the big fight at
the village taking down the Imperial
Walker
it was actually a pretty decent fight
scene for being so short but like I said
the whole thing here is that it's meant
to be a reference to the Ewoks fighting
the Imperials during Return of the Jedi
so they're not meant to be really
amazing fighters after they defeat them
the Mandalorian decides he's going to
leave baby Yoda with the village and
they kind of play it like maybe he's
considering staying for a brief second
but it's only halfway through the series
and we know there's going to be a season
two so of course he was never going to
stay at the village there's a little bit
of chemistry between him and the woman
O'Mara and he explains that if he takes
his helmet off he can never put it back
on again you learned a little bit more
about his backstory during this episode
like he says I was about their age the
little kids when I put the helmet on for
the first time the Mandalorians took me
in and they were good to me that also
lets you know that you don't need to be
born into one of the Mandalorian clans
to become a Mandalorian but number one
the new bounty hunter almost kills baby
Yoda right as he gets the kid in his
crosshairs they cut it so that you don't
quite see what happens but you hear the
blaster shot so you do wonder if he's
dead for just a second but then you get
the reveal that Cara Doon got him from
behind it's also a bit of a callback to
him calling him a womp rat bullseye womp
rats in the t16 young Luke Skywalker on
Tatooine would be proud the Mandalorian
realizes that he has to take the kid
with him because not only will he always
be in danger his presence in the village
will also endanger all these people they
make for a second like he's going to offer
Cara Doon a spot on his crew but then
they go their separate ways
saying until we meet again which will
probably be in season two because Cara
Doon Gina Carano was posting pictures
from behind the scenes while they're
filming season two a couple weeks ago
they've been a couple faints where you
think that he's going to take new crew
members on but if you think about it
there's really only space for two two
and a half people inside that cockpit
including baby Yoda so it's not like
he's going to be flying around with a giant
crew like you would see on the
Millennium Falcon in the original
trilogy the synopsis for Episode five
next week just says that he's going up
against a rookie bounty hunter so that
might wind up being bill burrs character
yes bill burr is playing a character on
Star Wars the Mandalorian but have you
spotted any other big Easter eggs that I
didn't mention in the video just write
them in the comments below I will be
doing more bonus videos for the
Mandalorian this weekend so leave all
your requests in the comments - if
there's a big question or a special
video that you want me to make next week
is also going to be big for
Marvel trailers and DC movie trailers so
as long as you have alerts enabled for
my channel you'll see those videos when
I post them I'll name a giveaway winner
when I post my next Mandalorian video
everyone click here for my brand-new
baby Yoda Mandalorian history video and
click here for my Mandalorian episode 3
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome
I have spoken.